N
WOLWS
FROM THE OF THE LATEST
TAINT FLORIDA NOW ECORD NUMBER
MASKS IN SLST T  ESCALATING VER
TONIGHT.ONAL CORRESPONDENT  OAN
US.E OUEWS eporter: RIGHTTATEME
THREATENED TO WITHHOLD FUNDING I
MASK
RE WITHHOLTHE
DICTS S OSUPERIDEHOOL
WHERE MASKAR
AND
N TO EXPLAIY WANTO
NAR THIS CONSEQUENCE
E STUDENTS IN  N CHF CREA
THOSDIS.
AND I WANT TO READ A PAR
AT THA
EDUCN  INTEN
FOREMOST, T SYEMS.
PROTECTING PARENTS' TS AND
ENSURING THAT EVERSTS
AND WED MENTION THAT THERE
ARE ALREADY UPLE, MULTIPLE IS IG
WITH CHILDREN WITH COM
IMMU
AND SO THIS IS BSOMETHING THAT T
OPE ONHE PEOPLE WE'VE TALKED
HE IN ORANGININTENSION WITH A
PARENTS, AMO S, LOCAL ANDOFFICI.
THERE'S ONE PARENT WSPOKE TO
TODAY WHO O THIS
12-YEAR-OLD TO VACCINATED. S YON
POTENT OUTR KIDS WHOSE
TAKIHE ON, ESPECIAE CHILDREN WHE
YET TO GET VACCID.
IF YOU LOOK AT TAY
AVE  CASES IN FL
YOU ASY
OR SO.CI
THE TIME WHESCHOOLS BRINGING STK
CLASSROOMS
TOMORROW, F SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN F C
COUNTY, HILL YOU, PALM
BEACEE COUNTIES.
THEY CURRENTLY ALL HAV
STATE PO, AL  BEOF THE
OPT OUT OF THAT,
WOLF.
>> AND JUST TO NATASHA
FLORRTED MORD-19
S ASHAN
HALF PANMIREN E UNITED
NATASHA, THANK YORE ONLL
.
OUR CHITLAN COLLINS IS
JOINING US
TH EATE
BETWEEN PRESIDENT BIDEN
OR DeSANTIS, R?
>> IT CERTAINL
CASAGE THAT
HEARD FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN LAS
WEEK TO REPUBLICAN GOV
HAVE BEEN TAKINGIKE
GOING TO HELHELPTUTINGE  MEASUR
LEAST T OUT OF THE WAY A
DON'T STAND IN THE WAY OF
WHO ARE O IMPLEMENT
THEFE NO RESPONSE FROM THETEO T
NEI GOVERNOR DeSANTIS'
OFFI
SHOTS ARE GOING TO GET ANY
GUIDANR OR NOT THEY
SHOU BCOMMENDED SOON
BECAUSE WE ARE NOW LEARNING THV
WILL BG ON FRIDAETHER OR NOT WE
SEEN BECAUSE RIG THE
AGENDA THAT WE HAVE JUST
TH HAVING A DISCSI
ABOUT BOOSTER SHAND NOTHAT THE N
EARLEMBER R
LAYING OUT THEIRATHOOULD GET BO
LIKE.TTIE SHOULD LOO
THOUGH DR. FAUCI HAS MADE TY
R N ON
IMMUNOCOMPROMISER
COE  WE ALMOST CERTAINLYOOSTING
WE BOOST THE GENERAL POPULATION.
HE SAID WE SHOUL DOING THAT N.
ISCOF
BREAKTHROUGH
BUT CNN HAS REVIED LATEST
DATA FROM THE CDC ON
BRKT
THE UNITED
ES
AND RIGHT NOW MO THA
ULLYINATEDE
BRASE TH HOSPITALIZATION OR DEA
WOLF YEAH,REALLY, REALLY
IMPORTANT.
BOTTOM LINE, GET AOUVEN'T GOTTE
RIGHT AWAY.ILU KN
KAITLAN, INOW D WITH A MANDATEA
MILITARY PERSONNEL, 1.5 MILLION
TREARNING ABOUT.
>> THIS IS A MEMO THAT
THE DEFEE SECRETARY LLOYD
MID-SEPTEMBEHEG TO B
SEEKING A MANDATE FROM THE W
HOUSE TOESREQUIRED FOR ALL MILIR
OF COUE,ETTHAT HASN --T HASN'T
GONE THAT FAR YECAE THEY
WERE WAITINGY WEREGOING TO GET
SINCGHT NOE VACCINE JUSTATION.
MILITARS
Y VACCINATED BY
SEPTEMBER , BUT BY THATE
WHITE HO THE SEEDEFENS
VACCINES AMONG THE
MILITARY.
IS TO
COME DOWN FR PEN.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE ANE
ON ARE BH SAYINGT
THEY BELIEVE THAT FULLCOULD HAP
COURSE THE PENTAGON COULD
REQUIRE THOSE CC
EVERYONEGHT NOW THEY'RE ES
WOG  PLANS TO
EMAT AND HOW THEY
WOULD ACTUALLY GF
THE MILITARY TPEOPLE
VACCINATED.
VACCINES, ALSO MOVQURIZATION USO
AUTHORIZED FOR CERTAINDIVIDUS
KAITHA YCH.CO
THE WHITE HOUSE.
T THISR HOTEZ IS JOINING
E  THE T
VACCINE LO HTAL CENTEROR
FOR JOINING
USURNING TS HEFLORIDA GORN RON
DeSANTISE STEP TO MK MANDATES
FOR THESE KIDS IN S.
YOU' SK EFFORTS
IN YOUE OF TEXAS.
AL
RPES, PUTTING THESKI AT UNNECES?
>> YEAH,HAT'S ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT, WOLF.
THIS IS SO SELF-DEFEATING.
LOOK WHAT'
LOTS O OF KIDS BEING EEN
UN NUMBERS TO THPOINER PEDIATRIC
GEG OVERWHELMED.TS PICUS A
NOW, SOME OFT ERE'S
ALN ANOTHER RESPIRATORY
S ED RSV GOING
BUT A LOT OF COVIDS
WELL.
IF WE'RE SEEING COVID-19
IPITALIZATIONS
BEFORE SCHOOL'S
OLS AR O HAPPER THAT?
S  W
HAVE KIDMASKED.INT I T
HEARD S SPEAKINGOT EVEGOING TO
S.L OF THE ADOLESCENTSND REALLY
MANDATES FOR THE
17-YEAR-OLDS IN THE SCHOOLS.
D .
BECAUSE IN THE SOUTH RIG NE GOT,
MISSISSIPPI, ET CETERA
ABOUHESCENTSINATED. VAST MAJORI
VACCINATED
TIES NOT FARM N WHERE THERE ARMA
ER
G
FIGHTING CHANCE TO HAVE A SFUL I
VACCINE ELIGIBLE TO GET THAT
DONE OR WEARING MASKS.
PEOPLE ARE ORATHOUGH
THIS DIRUSSAME
PREVIOUS LINEAGES.
IT'S NOT
TRANSMISSIBLE.
HE KIDS ARE GETTING SICK.>> IE
W
NEAKEN.ELASSROOMS.AND THESE AREI
YOU'RE JOI U
WHERE WE HAVE NEW IMAGES, LOOK
FROM
HERE A TENNO T IS,G CAPACITY.,
>> WE ARE.N A DIFFERENT AND
NOUS WAY, WHICH
BEING HOSPITALIZED.E MEDIAN IN
MEDICAL CENTER, WHICH IS THE RLR
Is OU
YTVE BEFORE. THIDE
ESSENTIALLY HITTING ANYONE VACC.
GEAWAY WUT VAT NOUCE GOING TO